I guess the most commendable thing he's
done is not decide you know to bomb Iran
or something I can think of things he
hasn't done and it's commendable that he
hasn't done them but he can point to
very little that at least by my
standards is commendable
I mean he's retracted some of the more
extreme Bush positions so for example
say on Cuba Bush imposed condition I
mean the normal conditions are totally
outlandish and ridiculous which is why
everyone except Israel votes against
them at the UN and why the majority of
Americans object to them but Bush went
way beyond he imposed even harsher
conditions and Obama we threw some of
those on nuclear issues he has indicated
that the US should return to the
mainstream of international affairs a
sign they consider again the
Comprehensive Test Ban Treaty moved
towards reducing nuclear weapons okay
that's a step forward from Bush's
position but it's a step towards the
center and towards the International
mainstream and also towards an American
public opinion and there's a number of
other cases like that where at the the
Bush administration especially its first
term was quite extreme which is why the
u.s. standing in the world fell to
historic lows
nothing much because I never expected
anything I was a little surprised by the
fact that he reinstituted some of the
the judicial practices that we're kind
of unconscionable that Bush made use of
like he wants preventive detention
permanently
he's been waffling about torture he's
refusing to grant normal criminal trials
to people that they have no evidence
against they claim to have done things
like that have been a little surprising
I don't think he had to be that extreme
and in his interpretation of actually
deviation from any reasonable legal
system